manhunt is underway in Tennessee for a
suspect accused of killing a sheriff's
deputy Steven Wiggins is considered
armed and dangerous he's wanted for
allegedly shooting and killing Dickson
County sergeant Daniel Baker during a
traffic stop yesterday officers arrested
and alleged accomplice overnight in
connection with the shooting mark
Strassmann is at at a search command
center in dickson tennessee mark good
morning good morning investigators
already have Erica Castner miles in
custody she is described as an
acquaintance of Wiggins and an accessory
to the slain deputy's killing she's
behind bars in a first-degree murder
charge while the manhunt goes on for the
primary suspects not only has our agency
lost a brother but our community is lost
a hero
investigators say 32 year old sergeant
Daniel Baker had responded to a call
about a suspicious vehicle around 7 a.m.
on Wednesday
when he stopped answering his radio
police used GPS to track down his patrol
car
it was located in a wooded area about
two miles away from the location of the
initial call the deputy was found inside
the car deceased it's unclear exactly
what happened in the moments before the
shooting but investigators say video
surveillance from the scene points to
Stephon Wiggins as the shooter my
message to him is that he needs to be
turning himself in he needs to be held
accountable
Baker joined the Sheriff's Office in
2008 and was known for his bravery on
and off the job in 2013 he helped rescue
a woman trapped underwater after her
truck overturned in a creek and in March
while off-duty and working a side
security job he chased after a drunken
gunman who fired a handgun into the air
Baker detained the suspect until police
arrived
Baker was also a veteran serving with
the US Marine Corps Reserve he was
married with a young daughter and came
from a family of police officers now his
extended law enforcement family searches
for his killer it is my prayer to God
that our court will be a terror to him
on the punishment he receives Wiggins
has a violent criminal history that goes
back a decade and was wanted on multiple
warrants when he was stopped by Baker
the suspect search for him goes on and
it will be unrelenting Nora all right
mark thank you so much